شرائح توضع في مخ البشر امر لطالم شهدناه
في افلام الخيال العميق وقد يصبح حقيقه
وواقعا قريبا جدا الى الماسك علينا قبل
عده ايام على بدء التجارب على البشر في
غضون سته اشهر باستخدام اداه لاسلكيات
اطورها شركات نيورا لينك المتخصصه في صنع
شرائح المخ الموضوع اثار الجدل بين الناس
والشكوك والمخاوف بين المختصين فشركه
نيورا لينك التي تقوم بتطوير وصلات
تاريخيه للمخ بهدف منح المرضى المصابين في
اعاقه القدره عن الحركه والتواصل من جديد
لديها تاريخ في التخلف عن الجدول الزمني
كما ان يرى لي كانت لديها خلافات بشان
تجاربها على القرود التي اجرتها في
الاعوام القليله الماضيه بعد ان اظهرت
السجلات تسببها في التهابات المزمنه ونبات
صراحه وشلل ونزيف لهذه الحيوانات قبل ان
يتم قتلها في النهايه تفاصيل اداه نوراليك
مع زميلا لمسرح
نور عليك شركه امريكيه للتكنولوجيا
العصبيه تعتمد على تقنيه تربط الاعصاب
والمخ البشري باجهزه الكمبيوتر من خلال
رقائق الكترونيه في قشره الدماغ حيث يتم
زرعها من خلال جهاز طبيا متخصص
تتواصل تلك الرقائق مع اجهزه الكمبيوتر
والهاتف الذكي بما يساعد على تحسين وظائف
الدماغ البشري والتفكير
والتحبقيه اعضاء الجسم يتم تثبيت الرقائق
بواسطه روبوتات عندما انشائه بواسطه
تشتركه احد الجراحين حيث يقوم بعمل فتح
بحجم اثنين ملي متر في جمجمه الشخص وتقوم
الشريحه بسبب في جمجمه المريض تحدث الشركه
بذلك الى تقديم علاج متقدم بحالات المرضيه
المرتبطه بامراض الجهاز العصبي المركزي
للانسان والتي لا يوجد لها علاج اول
تطبيقين مستهدفين في التجارب على البشر
باستخدام
استعاده البصر وايتاحه الحركه لعضلات
الاشخاص العزيزين عن ذلك
تامروه في ان تبدا بزرع الرقائق
الالكترونيه في ادمغه البشر خلال سته اشهر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اتحدث اكثر عن تفاصيل الموضوع
والاستشاره في جراحه الاعصاب دكتور عبد
السلام ابو بكر البلوشي دكتور يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك معنا في العربيه
صباح النور طيب دكتور شرائح الكترونيه
بحجم عمله معدنيه وعده بها ماسك ستكون في
ادمغه البشر في غضون سته اشهر بحسب المعلن
من الناحيه الطبيه كيف ستزرع ومدى السهول
زراعتها في دماغ البشر
اشرح
المشروع اللي عند الى الماسك هذا يعني
نموذج من جمجمه الانسان
من احد همم اهداف الرئيسيه حق الجهاز هذا
الجهاز راح يكون حجمه اثنين سنتي
يعني
الشغله الاولى
يكون ازاله من
يعني جزء قطع بسيطه من جمجمه الانسان هذا
هذا العمليه راح يسويها جراح مخ
والدرجه الثانيه دخول
الخيوط اللي راح تكون لاصقه مع الجيب هذا
باستخدام روبوت معين الروبوت هذا من شركه
على استخدام الشيب هذا
الناس اللي مصابين عندهم نصف عندهم شل
النصفي او شلل رباعي يبغى له
هنا
يعني في المخ وبعدين
في حبل الشوكي بيكون بين بين التواصل بين
النرويك هنا وهنا
الناس العادين لو انا ابغى احرك اصابع
لازم الاشاره تجي من المخ تروح الى رقبتي
حبل الشوكي الى الاعصاب بعدين اقدر احرك
اصابعي بس الناس اللي عندهم حاله شلل ضربه
في رقبتك يكون بين مواصله بين النيران هنا
وهنا والرقبه عشان الشخص هذه يحرك بيننا
انا صراحه معجب الان مصر فهو الاذكى ناس
اللي عرفه في جيلنا هذا
واتوقع ان ان رح ينجح في انجازات انا مع
اني ابغى اثر الايجابيات
من الناحيه الثانيه يا دكتور هل بالفعل
هكذا شرائح يمكن ان تعيد الحركه للمصابين
بالشلل ويمكن ان تعيد الابصار للمصابين
بفقدان الرؤيه الطبيه
طبيا قام
في احتمال بس الاشياء الي ما حد يذكر عنا
ان هذه عمليه عمليه
بامكاني يغير الشريحه
بسهوله مثل ما يقول انه ما حد يبغى ايفون
كل واحد يبغى ايفون 14 لان 14 اسرع واقوى
وكذا
واحد يقدر يطلعه ويستخدم على
اه لان مضاعفات مثل حاله صرعه السكته
دماغيه نزيه او موت وبعد يعني كل واحد
يبغى يركز على ايجابيات المشروع هذا شو عن
سلبيات يعني
التجربه هذه السواء على حيوانات وما ندري
عدد الحيوانات اللي ماتوا يعني
واشياء هذه وبعدين ادعي انه يقدر في
التجاره على الانسان على مستوى امريكا
خلاص سته شهور
دكتور يعني تجارب عن الحيوانات اظهرت همم
ظهور نزيف داخلي اصابات بالصرع وحتى
التهابات انتم دكاتره الى اما ده سهل
عليكم انه تزرعوا هذه الشريحه في دماغ
الانسان من دون حدوث
صعب جدا صعب فما ما اعتقد ان هذا سهل
الدرجه ان يدعي ان بس يحط الشريحه هذا
داخل الانسان المخ وفجاه يعني يرجع ال ال
الوظائف يعني الواحد يقدر يحرك ايدينا
وريوله بعد ما يكون عندها حاله شلل فهذا
صعب جدا مو بسهوله يعني نحنا انا يعني مخ
الانسان مو سياره مو بالماكينه معينه هذه
قاعدين نتكلم عن خلايا الجسم همم ما اعتقد
انها همم راح يقدر يعني يبدا
بالتجارب في على الانسان خلال سته شهور هل
في المستقبل يمكن بس حاليا مع المعلومات
اللي عنا من الشركه هذا
طيب انتم دكتور
معكم لهم ماسك مثلا ما الذي تنصحونه حتى
يعني تنجح فكرته بالزرع هذه الشرائح في
الدماء الدماء البشر
انا يعني البراءه اختراعي هو تقريبا نفس
بس انا ما الجهاز اللي طاحته ما ابغى ادخل
شيء تدخل جراحي يكون خارج الجمجمه
بالبدايه الواحد يركز على اشياء يتاك
د الثانيه يعني
يصير صعب الحيوان تجربه الحيوان اللي اللي
قريته عندنا باحد المقال 19 من 23 حيوان
ماتوا خلال التجربه هذه صعبه الواحد يعني
يقتنع فيه حتى لو اشتغل بعدين انا كان
جراح اسوي عمليات بنشوف كده
عمليات يعني تقريبا نوعا ما الدخول
داخل الموقع وترجع تسوي عمليه مره ثانيه
بيكون
نسبه نجاح يكون اقل فكيف الواحد يقول انا
تقدر تغير الموديل من ايفون 1 الى ايفون
مره ثانيه
على كل لمسه
ما راح يعني
بعيد الوظائف الخلايا مره ثانيه
ما تفتحش كان جزيلا لك من دالاس الجراح
والاستشاري في جراحه الاعصاب دكتور عبد
السلام ابو بكر البوشي شكرا جزيلا دكتور